[Music]
look at the camera
welcome back to CBS this morning are you
as excited as I am I love music I love
all forms of music in today's a day
we've been waiting for for a long time
to announce the Recording Academy's 62nd
annual Grammy Award nominations only on
CBS this morning we are revealing the
nominations for top categories including
Best New Artist record of the year song
of the year an album of the Year Grammy
award-winning singer-songwriter Alicia
Keys is returning the host music's
biggest night and she's also here to
reveal the nominees for best new artist
Kay's is very familiar with this
category she won it in 2002 please
welcome
Alicia key we are so glad that you're
you're coming back to host but I think
it's interesting at the end of last
year's show I remember a shot of you
walking you know where I'm going walking
backstage and they said Alicia would you
come back and do it again and you said
once is enough but I heard on The Oprah
Winfrey Show you always have the right
to change your mind say what changed
your mind
thank you so much you know honestly I
did think one time would be I mean it's
quite just clearing it Alicia he was so
good you knew you were gonna come back
and ask you a feeling but but no truly I
just thought that it would be you know
it's almost like a marathon you know you
kind of run the marathon one time and
then you said I did it and but in
actuality I ran another marathon and
then I'm doing another Grammys hosting
let's go
this is what I wonder about you you know
when they talk about the Oscars they
always say Billy Crystal is the
standard-bearer people are always trying
to live a bit but now I feel you have to
top your well do you feel you have to
top yourself you did the to piano I've
never seen anybody do that
I said hazel Scott that was a tribute to
Hazel's magnificent she's an incredible
pianist who was the first actually black
person period to have their own variety
show and she's incredible when you see
her play it's literally mine Bentley's
you know when at Everest most people
have never seen that before so when we
saw that we thought what are you
planning this year are you or do you
feel self-imposed pressure for yourself
you know honestly I feel so good I mean
I feel like now I know more than ever
I'm familiar with the space on multiple
levels I'm familiar as an artist I'm
familiar as a creator I'm familiar now
as a an emcee a host a person that can
keep the vibe so I feel like more
excited I feel more confident I feel
more ready to like bust the roof off
that means we're gonna make it the best
thing you know it's gonna be and it's
gonna be an exciting inclusive and you
know beautiful experience and and that's
what I want to create and I have no
doubt that you can do that thank you
we were talking about you this morning
we did a piece on you from Alicia Keys
from the very beginning
Kevon I can't do it even when I have a
voice their look has changed certainly
over the years I feel like that we've
watched you grow up yeah you know what
it's like to win a Grammy and to be
nominated yeah can you take us back to
that time what that meant for you
personally and how you sort of how you
wrap your your head around that as a
years ago it never gets old
oh no I mean it's so incredible to be
honored and to be recognized for the
work and the time and the creativity
that you put into your art and obviously
artists you know we love what we do so
much and it's something that we live and
breathe and you know believe in and so
to have that recognition it will never
get old it'll never be stale it'll
always you always feel nervous you're
always because I always feel nervous you
know
you feel you know that that's that
excitement that thrilled that feeling of
you know it it's nerves it's positive
you know so it doesn't get old it
remains exciting and I think it
continues to be a goal you know we get
to go over to the podium illusion
because Alicia's going to announce the
first one poison the moment we've all
been waiting for and you have a new
record out today - it is called time
machine and it's just driving today
today we've been waiting for the
nominations for the 62nd annual Grammy
Awards Alicia's gonna start with the
category let me know something very well
about Best New Artist well you have the
choir all right here I go this is
exciting I think you know as the best
new artist is really promising powerful
nomination and also award to receive you
know it says a lot about who you are and
what you're up to and where you're going
and so I'm excited to announce the
nominees for best new artist black Pumas
yes really Eilish little nice x's Liz oh
yes Maggie Roger oh so good Rosalia
really good Hank
and the bangers and Yola this is really
hard
oh my god yeah are you gonna pick
favorite you can't prorate in the host
why not right now but later later okay
look I have a lot of favorites in this
group this is actually a really powerful
group of artists and I love I love these
artists I think they're all bringing
something fresh they're all bringing
something unique and new and I'm so
excited that we're at this place in
music that we can really experience a
diversity that's encouraged and I think
that's what we want to see on the
Grammys alright Alicia Keys we're gonna
look for you to blow the roof off bang
on Grammy night great thank you thank
you very much
you have to leave just to point Q so
much say later okay our next degree
where you have another special guest to
the stage to help us announce more
Grammy nominations come on up
singer-songwriter bebe Rexha she's like
the female empowerment anthem we all
know it you can't stop the girl she's
also you know what this is like Vivi
she's a two-time Grammy nominee herself
hello bebe Rexha hi you're gonna next
you're gonna announce the next category
which is song of the year that's for you
okay thank you okay so today just start
yes yes you just started okay
song of the year bebe Rexha the nominees
are always remember us this way and the
songwriters are Natalie hem beat Lady
Gaga Hilary Lindsey and Lori McKenna bad
guy Billy Eilish O'Connell and Phineas
O'Connell bring my flowers now Brandi
Carlile fill hands are off Tim Hansa
Roth and Tanya Tucker hard place Ruby
and Lefou Sam Ashworth Dr Silius Harris
her and Rodney Jerkins lover Taylor
Swift Norman effing Rockwell don't you
dare Norman effing Rockwell by Jack
Antonoff
and Lana Del Rey someone you love by Tom
Barnes Lewis Capaldi Pete Kelleher
Benjamin cone cone sorry
and Sam Roman and truth hurts by Stephen
Chung Erik Frederick Melissa Jefferson
and Jessie st. John okay baby don't
leave I'll read the next category
because I have the envelope here for a
record of the year BB just did song of
the year
I've got Hema bon iver bad guy Billy
Eilish seven rings ariana grande a hard
place that would be her talk Cali
Old Town Road little Nozick's featuring
Billy Ray Cyrus Christmas Grammy that's
cool truth hurts Liz oh and sunflower by
post Malone and sway Lee okay in the
last category is you album of the year
one of the here we go okay I always get
nervous I'm like Dumas or something okay
album of the year III boney bear Norman
effing Rockwell by Lana Del Ray when we
all fall asleep where do we go by Billie
Eilish Thank You next Ariana Grande I
used to know her her 7 Lunas ex cuz I
love you Liz Oh hmm father of the bride
Vampire Weekend's those are all very
good choices bebe Rexha you know what
this is like when you were nominated for
your first Grammy were you up actually
watching it or do you do with so many
people say I was asleep and then I got
all these Texas were you up watching oh
I was actually I was watching the screen
and Best New Artist was last yes and I
was like please let meant to be be
nominated meant to be Alize and then I
gave up after and then like the last
literally I was the last name called
like broke down you know you grow up
wanting to win a Grammy and be part of
the Grammys it's like it's you all your
peers kind of giving you to your nod you
know what it was it's it's the most
incredible feeling so I'm really happy
for a lot of these people and now bébé
rex that you are part of the clubs thank
you so much for getting up early with us
we really really appreciate it we will
all be watching on Grammy night big
congratulations to all the nominees
today for music's biggest night and the
62nd annual Grammy Awards will air win
BB January 26 right here on CBS we like
CBS around here Tony back to you so we
do like CBS we'd like those nominees to
go thanks a lot I wonder any any truth
to the rumor that your voice is a little
bit scratchy because you've been singing
along
he said is there any chance to the rumor
that your voice is scratchy because
you're singing I do love to sing but I
have a bad voice it's just I woke up I
woke up like this you know your exciting
morning though guys yeah great list a
really great list and women leading the
way and album of the year very cool
thank you all right yeah thank you very
much